you said I think to to Sean Carroll
uh by the way everyone should go check
out Sean Carroll's mindscape podcast
it's incredible and Sean Carroll is an
incredible person I think he said there
maybe in a paper I have a quote you said
that a soft particle is a particle
that has zero energy just like you said
No and when the energy goes to zero
because the energy is proportional to
the wave of length it's also spread over
an infinitely large distance if you like
it's spread over the whole universe
it somehow runs off to the boundary what
we learned from that is that if you add
a zero energy particle to the vacuum you
get a new state and so there are
infinitely many vacua
plural for vacuum which can be thought
of as being different from one another
by the addition of soft photons or soft
gravitons right can you uh elaborate on
this wild idea
if you like it spreads over the whole
universe when the energy goes to zero
because the energy is proportional to
the wavelength it also spreads over an
infinitely large distance if you like
it's spread over the whole unit it's
spread over the whole universe what um
can you explain these soft gravitons of
photons
yeah so the soft gravitons and photons
um have been uh known about since the
60s
but exactly what we're supposed to do
with them or how we're supposed to think
about them
um I think has been
well understood
only recently
and in quantum mechanics the energy of a
particle
is proportional to Planck's constant
times its wavelength
so when the energy goes to zero the
wavelength gets goes to Infinity now
if something has
uh zero energy and it's spread all over
the universe
in what sense is it actually there
that's yeah that's been the confusing
thing
uh to make a precise statement about
when something is and isn't there
now the simplest way of seeing
so people might have taken the point of
view
that if it has zero energy and is spread
all over the universe it's not there we
can ignore it hmm
um but if you do this you'll get into
trouble
and one of the ways that you'll get into
trouble is that even though it has zero
energy it doesn't have zero angular
momentum
if it's a photon it always has angular
momentum one if it's a graviton it's uh
angular momentum two
so you can't say that the state of the
system with the Zero Energy Photon
should be identified with the one
without the Zero Energy Photon that we
can just ignore them because then you
will conclude that angular momentum is
not conserved
and if angular momentum is not conserved
things won't be consistent
and um and of course you can have a lot
of these things and typically you do get
a lot of them
and when you you can actually do a
calculation that shows that every time
you scatter
two particles you create an infinite
number of them infinite number of the
soft photons of the Zero Energy ones
yeah and so these are and there's
somehow everywhere but they're
everywhere but they're also contained
information or they're able to store
information and they're able to store
information they're able to store an
arbitrary large amount of information
so what we pointed out is
so what these things really do one way
of thinking of them is they rush off to
the edges of the universe
spreading out all over the space is like
saying they rush off to the energy edge
of the universe right
and that includes if the interior of the
black hole is not considered part of the
universe that includes the edge of the
black hole
so we need to set up our description of
physics
so that all the things that are
conserved
are still conserved in the way that
we're describing them and that will not
be true if we ignore these things we
have to keep careful track of these
things
and people had been sloppy about that
that and we learned how to be very
precise and careful about it and this
and once you're being precise you can
actually uh that makes you can actually
answer this kind of very problematic
thing that Hawking suggested that black
holes destroy information well what we
showed is that there's an error in the
argument
that all black holes are the same
because they hadn't kept track of these
uh these very subtle things
and
um whether or not
this is the key error in the argument
remains to be seen or whether this is a
technical Point yes but it is an error
it is an error and uh Hawking obviously
agreed with it Hawking agreed with it
and he was sure that this was the he was
sure that this was this was a critical
error that this was the critical error
and that understanding this would would
would get us the whole story and and and
and and that could well be what was it
like working with Stephen Hawking in
this particular uh problem because it's
kind of a whole journey right well you
know I I I I love the guy I he's so
passionate about
physics
uh he just
yeah his
his Oneness with
the problem and uh I mean it's
so his mind is all occupied by the world
that's uh yeah well let me tell you
there's a lot of other things with his
illness and with his celebrity and yeah
a lot of other things
a lot of distractions pulling it is uh
at his mind he's still there that's
right I remember him turning down
tea with Lady Gaga so we could spend
another hour on our paper
[Laughter]
that my friends is dedication what did
you learn about physics what did you
learn about life uh from uh having
worked uh with Stephen Hawking well he
was one of my great teachers of course
he's he's older than me and I was I was
reading his um
his textbooks in in um
in graduate school and um
uh you know I learned a lot about uh
relativity from him I learned about
passion for a problem I I learned about
um
not caring what other
people think you know I mean physics
isn't
interesting culture even if you make a
great discovery
like Walking Dead
people don't believe everything you say
in fact people love to disagree
it's a it's a a culture that cherishes
disagreement and and so you know he kept
ahead with what he believed in and
sometimes he was right and sometimes he
was wrong do you feel pressure from the
community so for example with string
theory
it was very popular for a time there's a
bit of criticism or it's less popular
now do you feel the forces of the
community as it moves in and out of
different fields or do you try to stay
like how difficult is it to stay
intellectually and mathematically
independent from the community
personally
uh I'm lucky
I'm well equipped for that
I when I
started out in graduate school the
problem of quantum gravity was
not considered interesting
he still did it anyway I still did it
anyway I I'm a little bit of a
contrarian I guess and I think that has
has served me well
and uh
people are always sort of disagreeing
with me
and they're usually right but I'm right
enough
and like you said the contradiction
ultimately paves the path of discovery